so if you don't have them approaching
and you're the one that has to approach
you're setting yourself up to be with
the guy that's going to be beta very few
women will approach a guy and they'll
divorce them for sure break that down
you're saying that if a girl approaches
the guy yeah what's going to happen so
i've talked about this a lot because
this is what i used to do is if i liked
a guy i gave him my number i would date
him i'm like if i want it i have it type
thing but if
so what i figured out was if i do that i
end up leading in the relationship
inevitably because it's the first
encounter if the guy doesn't have the
balls to approach me he's probably not
alpha or probably isn't assertive enough
to the point where i would have genuine
desire for him then what happens in the
relationship i end up using him or i
can't look up to him he's like repulsive
to me because he's not the alpha and
taking charge
it doesn't even have to be alpha but
assertive traits like some traits it's
not like a full
like alpha i think is
a placeholder term but i'm talking about
traits like you have to have a mix of
both
you know rolo as the intersexual
dynamics expert here break down what
she's saying well i mean she it you
women cannot look up to a man that they
that they don't like they don't admire
they can't look up to an equal they
can't look up to somebody who is uh
when they meet him he's one way and when
they get together with him he becomes
something else
so it's uh what it does is it triggers
this existential fear in women that
their got with like the guy tricked them
and you you came off as looking like
justin waller and you look very you're
very high value and very alpha and
everything and then once you get into
that relationship then the guy turns
very passive vulnerable and emotional
goes really emotional and it's like it's
really a form of buyer's remorse almost
it's like buyers regret at that point
and it's triggering to women because
that is that remorse is attached to
their reproductive you know
solving the reproductive problem so if
she gets into a relationship with the
guy who sells himself as being like sort
of you know an alpha male guy and then
later on becomes beta then it's like oh
my god i got tricked you know and i
might actually have this guy's babies
how am i going to get out of this and
then there's also the uh the investment
cost that goes into that as well so
spending time with that guy developing a
relationship with that guy having sex
with that guy whatever it ends up being
you've got like three three months in
maybe a year in and you go oh my god
he's actually not like that he's he's
really kind of he's fried he pushed out
at the but what's wrong with that if you
date a guy for a month or two and it
just doesn't work out you're not
marrying this guy no that's a problem no
there's only a short amount of time
where women are at their sort of their
peak potential at that time and they're
trading that off for like saying okay
i'm going to put some time and energy
and investment into this guy and if it
turns out that he's he's not the guy
that's ready for the long he's not a
good long-term prospect because he sold
himself as one thing and then he became
something later on um like that's the
number one thing that guys will hit me
up about is they'll say rollo how do i
get the frame back i was so alpha when
we were dating and then we got married
and now i lost the frame she has no
respect for me and and you know i'm into
sexless marriage or whatever and she
wants babies but i don't know if we
should give her babies and so it's like
he be he was one thing when he was
single and he becomes something else
what do you tell them when they lose
this frame they they need to get back in
touch with that that uh like what was it
that made them
you know different when they were single
than they are when they're married and
then also it's like um the uh the they
need more polarity in the relationship
healthy relationships are not based on
like commonalities or compatibility or
you know open communications it's based
on polarity
likes do not attract
opposites attract even in the most
egalitarian countries they was they end
up falling into gender roles like they
choose to do that the women and the men
so that's in the most egalitarian what
is that scandinavian countries what are
the most okay yeah patients talk about
that what happens in these countries in
in the countries where women and men are
the most equal you can be
women end up falling into like the
nurturing role inevitably and men go
into like more masculine isn't that just
like the reversion to the mean you just
go into your natural sense it makes us
more sexual
yeah it's like um the more egalitarian a
country is the more that you will
be
what is it the differences are
exacerbated
so where's america in that
we're not we're not the most egalitarian
country in the world no we're fighting
that's why that's why they always look
at like say denmark and scandinavia and
like uh you know norway and stuff like
that as being the most egalitarian
countries and so that what what that is
meant the reason why they go there is
because the gender parity like
the
you know you've heard of what is it uh
equality of opportunity both men and
women can be anything they want to in
you know in those countries and women
tend to default to what we would
consider more conventionally feminine
jobs and roles and you know that kind of
stuff but what's wrong with that nothing
there's nothing but it shows you that
even when you make things equal even if
you make things equal women will stop
stay
there it is right there you're saying if
you can try all you freaking want to
make us exactly the same and exactly
equal but no no no no no it doesn't work
that way it it it is equality of outcome
right in that again
we try to make that's the do you wanna
know the difference between those
countries of this yeah we concentrate on
equality of outcome rather than a
quality of opportunity here well in some
ways
in some of the countries the outcome
there is a quality of outcome and that's
where it's like stupid economy wise
because you have a teacher making the
same as a doctor
[Music]